all right guys listen up I've done it I
don't know how but I've done it I know
you guys have been waiting for Resident
Evil 4 and it came out when I was very
busy with the movie and I always wanted
to play it because I've never actually
played the original and I was looking
forward to this but I've made it and I
don't know how I've done it now I need
you to listen very closely I got a
sponsor I got a sponsor to play this
game and I got a sponsor to play the
separate ways DLC right
this is with
her separate ways is story based DLC
coming to Resident Evil 4 that
shows it's here shows the mysterious
agent aah Wong's perspective and how her
actions inter intertwine with Leon S
Kennedy's for the president's missing
daughter in the full title now I know
you're looking forward to a full
playthrough but you got to bear with me
here I got a sponsor so you got to make
me look good because I don't get
sponsors I mean unless they're watching
this and then I get a lot of sponsors
I'm very good at doing the sponsor thing
and you guys know that I'm very good at
doing the sponsor thing and I get to
keep P sponsors and if I do this good
then I'm going to get more so you got to
make me look good right I don't even
think there's a link in there it's just
like you get play the game get the DLC
it's out now so I'm going to try this
and you
guys you guys got to cover for me I
don't know what's going on in this and I
won't know what's going on but I need
you to come comment as if I know what's
going on look I know this is unorthodox
but it's unorthodox for me to get a
sponsor at all so I know what I'm
talking about right Resident Evil 4 is a
critically acclaimed remake of the title
that changed horror and video games
forever and this is going to change my
life forever it's the latest in the line
of Resident Evil remakes from the
creators of Resident Evil 2 2019 and
Resident Evil 3 2020 I played those I
know Resident Evil and I do and I like
it and there's no question question
about that none of this is untrue the
only thing that might not be true is
that I know what I'm talking about but
you're going to make it seem like it's
true right it has a 93 Metacritic score
it is a certified must playay by
Metacritic and it's currently on sale
along with just ever about every other
title in the Resident Evil series I'm
the Resident Evil
guy right this is where you comment yes
you are the Resident Evil guy okay all
right there's also the mercenaries which
you can play and there's also currently
development a free VR update for
Resident Evil 4 and Playstation VR 2 so
you can experience Leon's story in a
totally New Perspective coming this
winter which I might try who knows oh I
didn't I didn't customize anything hold
on oh I mean I need to
re oh no the light of Lies has gone out
I need to reconfirm that all of my
settings are
good yeah let's do some Ray tracing
that'd be that'd be cool all right we're
going into this
[Music]
well I mean I am confident of my skills
but since separate ways is not only a
remake of the original PlayStation 2
release of the original title but it's
full of new mechanics and twists not in
the original title including A's
grappling gun that can be used for both
traversal and
combat so I'm going to do this on
standard otherwise I would just I I'm so
good
at the game which is now available on
PlayStation 4 5 Xbox x and S Xbox series
X and S and PC 10 bucks and you get this
if you have the game which you should
have and I
had
definitely please I'm I'm begging you I
I you got to make me look good you you
got it this is I'm sitting on a throne
of Lies but I have a sponsorship so it's
just like no matter what I got to get
through this and you got you got to help
me get through this okay all right
cool this is not
a that's this might be a I don't
know
[Music]
what hold on I got
to I don't want to interrupt
this I don't know if I hit
record
hold on quick quick is quick like bunny
I just got to make sure everything's
good everything's great
[Music]
everything's
okay
hi I'm
aah I love
dance
that's no way to finish a
dance you
naked Oh no you're
[Music]
not faite I believe excellent timing AER
you know how I feel about being tied
up
and
yes many thanks you see those annoying
monks took everything from
me including the
Amber no cleverly hidden just before
they grabbed
me well then lead the
way my pleasure as we all know Resident
Evil here we go all about the dance is
it close yeah it was a very Brave
exactly
mechanic No No Deal you know terms we're
good we're good what do you want with it
anyway I don't know yet it gave me an
opportunity to bust out my DDR pad and I
think it was very brave of them to
incorporate full DDR functionality
especially with the diagonal buttons um
even though it was mandatory and not
everyone has a diagonal pad uh but I did
and I I actually got it shipped in from
uh Ohio where I originally was playing
the original version of it um some
dubbed the game dancing of the dead and
I I I think that's slanderous because it
it may feature dance specifically but so
much more going on besides the
dance I'm hoping that when they meant
new mechanics and the grappling gun it's
um
feature DLC dances
we've got company they're looking for us
but we're taking the high road got it
understood up you go
Louise
oh
oh touch the amember we'll meet up later
no it's time for a a
lady
oh those aren't Dancing Fingers Church
let's not make it a funeral yeah uh-huh
don't
worry I've got this
all right all right we all I'm doing
[Applause]
it damn I'm
good ah man I thought I'd be rusty after
getting through the previous campaign
but okay
[Music]
[Applause]
hi ew
not bad not nearly good
enough oh yeah okay so repeat of what
you just saw of course okay well yeah
uh-huh yep I meant to do that yep uh-huh
that's how good I am we all know the
dance of the Parry oh okay
um
oh you you got fire
scream my my eyes
hello all
right uh-huh what
[Music]
[Applause]
is oh did
I oh I I
did I don't
remember
bugs I
mean bugs we all know and stay
gone that usually works whenever in
these games uh you request uh a monster
to stay to go and stay gone they always
stay gone I will admit like okay in all
seriousness it was unfortunate that I
was so busy during the release of this
game I really did want to play it um
because I hadn't played Resident Evil 4
somehow I didn't play any version of it
to ret
it control do you copy don't worry Li is
going to cut this part out so we can
maintain the
ruse we ran into some Wesker Adam
wker what will you do about it Louise is
already on route to the church I'm
tracking him every step of the way very
well then I suggest you
hurry
copy just need to confirm my route first
heading out to get a visual of the
area
oh what oh oh ah see I didn't play
Resident Evil 5 or 6 either so it's like
it's interesting to me to see stuff like
this and how it kind of comes full
circle to what those games are being
more like action oriented whereas like
what really brought Resident Evil back
was kind of like a a connection to the
horror of it all um oh hi that's where I
need to go stick to The High Ground you
have the
means I also have the
wherewithal the Amber Nothing Else
Matters okay wrap this little tour up
and bring it to me okie dokie then but
maybe a little sightseeing first I don't
I don't know about that I don't know if
that's a good use of my time I don't
know if that's the best way to go about
this paboo can I stealth kill or
something okay well that's what you get
oh oh oh oh wait a minute hold on I see
the errors of my way
heating up I'll need to disable the
catapults yeah will I oh
damn
whoa holy crap oh you're not
dead oh now you're
are I didn't know I can do that ooh
[Applause]
money Haya okay Haya
that's what you
get I'm not paying attention to the
right B DOA
does but someday I
will oh that's
awesome
ow that's great oh hi whoa ow okay hold
on ow I'm on fire this is unfortunate
for
me hold on
oh God damn that sweater must be a lot
tougher than it looks because wow that
was right in the
face um yeah uh-huh
okay all right d all
right well that was all right this is
going so
good uh oh no
no there we go
oh yes yes there we
are all right oh I have that that's fine
all right let's just I don't know where
I'm going I mean I know exactly where
I'm going you guys are I even if I'm
talking like this you really got to keep
up the r okay oh hi where were you you
got to keep up the ruse for me uh just
in in case any of my sponsors are
looking in the uh comments they'll just
see we all know that they don't watch
the whole video probably definitely
H uh but definitely keep up the ruse
just um leave comments like man he's so
good and knowledgeable about this game
and plays so
amazingly I can't think of a better
person to sponsor than this man in front
of us right right here
o
great oh my God that was I should not
have been oh my God I remember there
being a button who
oh I remember there being a I'm about to
die I remember there being a
button that's
unfortunate I
really shouldn't have zoomed down some
aha a grenade perfect watch this
guys there it is you think you're the
only one to throw what if I just shoot
him there's no one there there is I see
you
oh more than one or is that
it oh I got
you oh oh hey whoa whoa I heard that
okay whatever I'm just going to try to
go the way I should which I don't really
know what that
is oh I'm down here
now that's good that would have been
good sooner but I'll take
it whoa saw something
grapple
okay am I supposed to know when those
are
coming
oh my
God
please
okay can't
can yeah got what's the cannon button oh
come back here all right I'm going to
actually stealth can I
crouch apparently not nope no
need that is much better that is
significantly
better so if I stay stealthy are they
not going to get
me yeah all
right oh this is so much easier what was
I doing
before Oh Boy
okay yeah that makes sense yeah I get
that things are heating up I'll need to
disable the catapults I know I'm
aware oh boy that's a lot of fire uh no
yes little okay so there's one catapult
over here I know that's not good but I
just I'm trying to hurry
here that is so
useful
no okay you know what I'm just uh ow
it's
fine
Canon canon
ball okay well I missed but uh okay this
is unfortunate uh I should get the
Catapult
yeah it's a little
slow is that a
catap oh
oh nothing
personal why weren't they using the
catapults or the cannon I feel like the
cannon was the obvious
choice so is this like a bulletproof
sweater or
[Music]
something all
right
oh oh oh almost out of
here yeah um I was thinking about
sightseeing and then I I remembered I
got to get to my dance
lessons and that's the end of the uh a
Wong DLC I think that was
really really something special I um
glad I was able to experience it it was
uh it
was
something it's not going to tell me like
how many Secrets I missed or anything
like that cuz I know I had to have
missed a lot h riter ah all I don't want
to overwrite
my my save from the main game here
lixian please put in what looks like
saves ah I'll have to delete that one
but man that's uh oh that's really
something
atache all my collectibles that I got
from being the main game I deleted them
cuz I wanted the purity of the OG
experience
here really good stuff so he wants me to
retrieve the
Amber an object of ill
Omen what terrible actions will be done
in its name and who will pay its dark
cost
what because in this world someone
always
pays best not to ask who or
why all right we got Edge Lord Ada over
here I understand looks like that guy's
going to pay made my peace with it until
that one night in Raccoon
City changed
everything is that the Crystal from the
beginning of halflife that caused a
resonance
Cascade cuz then I can understand how
that would be
bad I'm heading to meet Lis at the
rendevu point now I'm seeing increased
movement from Los
eliminados don't get
careless copy Ada
out from the the illumin almost at the
church
to all right I'm almost at the church
I'm assuming the church is where the
Amber is and I remember that very
distinctly from the main game that's
handy lot L want some
soup there you
go all
right that is so nice
some tomato bisque for your
Dome sorry
Grand I know I know that they're
probably zombies but I I I haven't
exactly confirmed that so I'm not 100%
sure if I didn't just kill someone's
Grandma man this feels this feels proper
I I feel like everyone can understand
the this is there's a beeping over there
oh that's probably fine well I don't
want to alert
anyone don't
AAR all right that is tempting but I'm
being
stealthy I know like okay I'm sure that
plenty of people have said their
whatever comments they may have on the
outfit but just having a grenade right
off the belt draped over A's ass here is
just oh uhoh Sor right had to do it had
to do it had to do it had to do it to
him all
right but oh I probably not good okay oh
your head didn't do so good there buddy
oh wait a
minute all right we
done yeah you
done okay I don't know where I'm
going what's the
thumping and why is it going to be such
a good thing for
me anytime there's big ominous thumping
it's always turned out
well hello peekaboo
I can't seem to go through go up and
over where the bomb is I don't trust
that thank
you ah oh I didn't get the thing H from
the last one I'm sure that's a very
important collectible that I
neglected where do I go am I going the
wrong
way ah ah oh this is a perfect
opportunity for
three and
H aha oh you are not dead okay oh I'll
get you okay no I
won't oh my god oh you mind if I hold on
Sir one moment uno momento I'm just
going to
go all right you're going to get
blown did you get blown did it blow him
oh my God is he dead
oh that would have been really cool to
do to the big bull guy but uh I
didn't
nice that definitely wasn't being saved
for a family member for
sure I like that move a clean
strike I think everyone can agree and
we'll comment down below this was
clean
hi don't
worry I'm missing on purpose as a
warning oh hi it's a really good thing
that I knew you were there come on
Grandma thank you hold on okay well this
is
embarrassing sh I wish that
cleaved okay rude okay
Rudder can I
shoot sh that oh it did oh you're alive
ow I'm almost dead we got Grandma here
uh charging
down I should just aim for the body on
that one nope
nope okay I'm a little rusty it's been a
while I'm getting
there I'm getting there we on be withd I
don't know what the wisdom of that would
be oh I got to get over the obstacle
that's what the wisdom would be in case
you was wondering
yippe
so what's special about the Amber hi I'm
seeing quite the crowd here H I wonder
what has them so riled
up the president's
daughter
undoubtedly couldn't have picked a worst
time consider the village infected
complete local saturation I've read the
file I'll see what I can
do
uh-huh I knew all of this I think I v I
vaguely actually do know something about
that it's uh the president's daughter
was vacationing here and Leon had to
rescue her I do know that because I
played I know now I need you to comment
yeah he really didn't know about the
president's
daughter if there's one thing you're
commenting this if there one thing I
know about Mark is that he really knows
the president's
daughter not like that cut everything
out cut cut cut me out not out not
delete the Box cut me out of the box
thank you
look out there's an exploding Barrel
behind
you tried to warn them
what what what that a
pig that is a pig I was right it's a pig
that pig don't look so good oh that's a
cow oh Pig dead I don't think that was
me what is that
about I hope you're dead you better not
come back he's doing the thing can I can
I not do I have to I have to don't mind
me big don't let me oh
hello sorry
Grandma how this is one tough
Grandma okay
I didn't think there would be that many
people over
there um and I don't think it's crucial
to my sponsorship that I did know so you
don't have to comment um about how I
knew that there would be people there
because that is not
relevant did they add butt jiggle
physics look I know that you know when
humans
run they
jiggle I just feel
like how many hours of game development
went into making sure that the butt
jiggle physics was properly
calibrated I swear it's not like I don't
focus on these things but it's kind of
hard to
ignore it's just it's just a little
funny to me it's just funny me the
priorities in games and the realism you
know
okay that felt so mean that felt so
targeted and
mean
oh God I wish I had a grapple
gun
Leon why am I not
surprised why am I not surprised either
to keep our friends busy
let's see if we can find another route
to the
church all right we're seeing if we can
do
that does this way look promising I
don't know if promising is what I would
call
this should have looked behind you
dude what is with this big yellow
stain
you taking too many multivitamins or
something dude this is a lot of yellow
that is a lot of yellow usually yellow
means
something I don't know what
though okay that's
problem or it's not okay it's a problem
it's a
problem there doing so I'm not doing
anything I need to hurry I I really do I
really
hurry I'm trying to stay as still as
possible but the the the Perpetual
jiggle in my
cheeks I feel like I should have been
slightly more urgent okay let's try this
again ah I'm afraid am I supposed to
hurry or something really that was
it
oh oh oh here as well here as well okay
all
right this poor old lady God it just
feels so
mean all right oh okay the bell rang
today it has been so long since I last
heard it sound the ringing is the call
of Our Lord the whole village
congregated at the church to listen he
was as kind as ever we are growing
closer and our minds are becoming one he
even said that the Miracles we create
here shall soon Grace the entire world
what wisdom what compassion through our
Lord's benevolence we shall receive the
medicine to cure the madness I cannot
wait until the Bell Tolls
again me
neither you all right so is that what
the yellow was oh oh what are
you I've gotten one I'm pretty much a
pro hello is this going to collapse hi
what I'm already ahead of the curve oh I
glad I moved into that so I can catch it
on my Bulletproof you're not done oh yes
you
are oh yes you are
ah oh
H that makes
sense though I feel like I might have
been able to guess that I don't know how
high pressure you need to piss to cover
this much ground but that's that is
impressive that is so is like the triple
helix so triple helix the double swoops
and
um
ah that thing mushroom cloud so we got
the Oppenheimer got the double swoops
and the triple helix this thing oh they
shouldn't they shouldn't piss their door
codes onto the
walls this is Standard
Security it's really convenient that no
one notices me the church
I can see that um don't mind me don't
mind me don't mind me don't mind me
don't mind me grandma they really can't
hear can
they don't mind me they really didn't
mind
me
where is
he stood up
again sounds like you could use a little
help I'm I'm not going to do
it oh yes I
[Music]
am
l
oh
don't worry Leon first time's free
don't keep me waiting
Louis
huh we just lost ls's signal somewhere
in the vicinity of the
forest expect the
worst that's Mendes isn't
it he has a house there could be worth
taking a look do
it I'll see what I can find from my
end you you all right man you sick
should have known he keep
trouble sounds like you got something in
your throat where am I going am I going
back where was I supposed to go
Mendes we all know Mendes
right Mendes
women
Dez he they them
Dez excuse me I guess I'll go where you
came
from a it's dark a
grenade the old cupboard grenade excuse
me on to the church now you don't want
to be late
[Music]
goodbye I guess everything's all right
that's
[Music]
fun hi hey stranger so what are you
buying I don't know you've picked quite
the place to set up shop
stranger I and look what it brought
me well now let's make our first time
doing business a memorable
one okay all right
welcome
just be careful with that man all right
ah oh still have some new items you
might be interested in ah oh this kind
of tra
appear that cat in your pocket all your
life you threatening me okay what do I
have I have a Blacktail AC so if I get
Punisher MC so I can't get that you get
some bang for your buck I guarantee it
uh-huh H oh damn uh ooh Ruby's all
rubbish it makes no difference the price
well that's our choice to
make well our what do you mean what do
you mean our choice Life Is Ours to
choose is that what you're saying is
what he's saying a deal well
struck okay um I'll get a shotgun CH
mate your inventory is full let us know
when you've made some
room taada I guess I could combine down
some of those herbs okay oh all auto
swort well it's not as good as I did but
very easy to handle it will be perfect
for you what are you trying to say what
are you saying about me what are you
saying
all yours stranger don't get yourself
killed now trying not to all right is
that a table of
heads that's good that's good stuff
thanks
[Music]
dude well funny thing is I'm less
bothered by the table of heads out there
because I found a room full of
oh
Master if you pay some thought it is
unusual that Isidro let me go ever since
the beast in the black robe struck me
with something I've have been feeling
strange I have started seeing things
having visions the sky itself looks like
that of another world and then that
thing comes only now there are many
hundreds master I beg you please is
there a way to escape this
horror holy look at the Dome on this
dude damn all right this is a good place
hi who are you the leader of the cult
I have my answer and also I knew
that there's a lot of gunpowder
around that's a good
sound
oh good ah so what was that about the
sky being on fire that I heard about
good things are
happening won't let me go so easily huh
ah but I told you so nicely to stay
away oh boy here we go and evade why I
swear it's never given me the prompt to
evade since I missed it the first time
oh
that's not evading oh god oh oh oh oh no
oh no hold on hold on no no no no no
what is there a way to mix from three
can't you mix
three yes
yes yes all right you're done now whoa
boy you're done now bro okay he's done
oh
ah Parry this
okay why would you give me the option to
Parry if it wasn't going to work ooh
well there goes
that y i I
swear
hold on bear with me okay that's
problem what would that do increase
maximum yeah that's good
right
yeah bear with
me this The
Fakes you don't tell me which is
which oh boy
how about one of these oh wait no he's
doing the thing where he becomes
[Applause]
things oh boy okay you're not real is it
because he has glowing
eyes
probably looks like that was
effective what whoa whoa hey whoa whoa
you're not real don't slide my ass what
are you doing what you think you're
doing
uh-huh the fog it's getting
thicker uh it sure is oh I see
you out my way out my way hey you
actually hurt still wait come here
you take one of
these not fond of that are we I don't
know what I
did okay well that's a
problem don't mind just mixing up some
herbs yep you're done now one of these
days Elevate
you I guess I can just run away like
that woo
oh oh oh World All
Star
huh
[Applause]
I mean I've shot him like 15,000 times
already so that one was going to finish
him off for sure you're
lucky yeah you better
slunk you slunk on out of
here stay
slunk what is wrong with
me yeah I've never missed another shot
before that that is that is a first I
I'm now for the village Chief's
house yes that's what I'm doing it won't
open yes no it will not
chicken I felt mean why did I do that I
didn't mean
it it died
so
stupidly what have I done
what I
done I got to hide the
body got to hide the
body I got I got hide the body I got to
blow it over the fence I got to hide the
body the party oh God no
[Music]
no
check out Resident Evil
4 available on Playstation Xbox and PC
and check out the separate ways deal
see look um help me hide the
bodies thank
you what have I
done